el jefe del grupo Wagner ha sido
ejecutado todo apunta a que Vladimir
Putin al final cumplió su venganza lo
hizo exactamente dos meses después de
que el grupo de mercenarios más famoso
de Rusia protagonizará un sonado
alzamiento y marchará sobre Moscú para
denunciar el desastre en Ucrania Pues
bien todo eso ahora ya es historia el
jet comercial con matrícula Romeo Alfa
02795 propiedad del grupo Wagner se
estrelló este miércoles 23 de agosto de
2023 en la región de The beber tras
haber despegado de Moscú con dirección a
San Petersburgo este que veis en
pantalla es el avión cayendo Pero qué
pasó Exactamente para que esta aeronave
terminará estrellándose contra el suelo
pues lo cierto Es que según afirman
tanto los propios entornos del grupo
Wagner como fuentes de inteligencia
occidentales
el avión podría haber sido abatido Ni
más ni menos que por la defensa
antiaérea de Rusia presumiblemente en el
aparato viajaban el líder de Wagner
jeffgani precozin y su mano derecha y
responsable militar de la organización
el comandante de Wagner Dimitri udkin es
decir que estamos ante una Clara
ejecución todo apunta a que tras
asegurarse de que los dos pesos pesados
del grupo de mercenarios volaban
exactamente en el mismo avión el kremlin
decidió terminar con ellos por todo lo
alto
queridos amigos y amigas podemos decir
que ha sido la viva imagen de la
política rusa de las últimas décadas de
abrir a principios de los años 90 una
cadena de puestos de perritos calientes
y más tarde algún que otro restaurante
algo mejor puesto gracias a lo cual Por
cierto hizo relación con el presidente
ruso este Magnate de la restauración
terminó convirtiéndose en todo un señor
de la guerra lideró la que probablemente
es la empresa de mercenarios más
importante y conocida de todo el planeta
con negocios en Rusia África Oriente
medio y otras muchas partes del mundo
brigotchin llegó incluso a convertirse
en una de las caras más visibles de la
brutal invasión rusa de Ucrania digamos
que es la mejor representación posible
del capitalismo mafioso que impera en
Rusia sin embargo ahora su historia ha
llegado a su fin evidentemente todavía
son muchas las cosas que no conocemos y
que quizás no conozcamos nunca pero
desde luego también hay cosas que sí que
sabemos que ellos amigos amigas Qué ha
pasado exactamente Por qué Vladimir
Putin ha decidido cargarse al jefe de
los Wagner y sobre todo Por qué ha
decidido hacerlo ahora y otra cuestión
no precisamente menor Qué consecuencias
puede tener toda esta historia Pues bien
en este vídeo vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si hay una cosa Clara en todo este
asunto es que a Putin nunca le ha
temblado la mano a la hora de perseguir
Y acabar con sus contrincantes algo que
además ha hecho habitualmente de la
forma más terrorífica posible por
ejemplo el espía fugitivo ruso Alexander
lit vineco fue envenenado en la
cafetería de un hotel de Londres con
polonio radioactivo el político opositor
Boris name soft fue asesinado a tiros
junto a la plaza roja y la periodista
fue ejecutada en su propio domicilio
Estos son solo tres ejemplos de una
larga larguísima lista de personas que
han sido envenenadas tiroteadas o simple
y llanamente arrojadas por la ventana de
algún edificio alto de Rusia una lista A
la que podemos encontrar nombres tan
conocidos Como el del líder opositor
alexinapal un antiguo espía doble
afincado en Reino Unido dos tipos que se
salvaron por los pelos tras ser
brutalmente envenenados porque lo cierto
Es que en muchos casos las ejecuciones
promovidas por el presidente ruso no
solo buscan acabar con una determinada
persona sino también infligir el mayor
terror posible al resto de potenciales
adversarios
[Música]
pero ojo porque si esto ha sido una
constante en toda la era Putin la Guerra
de Ucrania ha marcado un antes y un
después ha sido todo un punto de
inflexión
[Música]
Y es que veréis si hasta ahora la
mayoría de las víctimas habían sido
oponentes formales de Putin personas que
criticaban abiertamente a su gobierno o
que a ojos de Moscú habían traicionado a
Rusia desde que Putin lanzara al
ejército ruso sobre Ucrania el tipo de
víctimas ha cambiado en los últimos
meses han perdido la vida un montón de
personas que formaban parte de lo que
podemos denominar como la élite
empresarial de Rusia miembros que tal
vez no eran del todo leales o que
manifestaban poco entusiasmo por la
guerra hablamos de ejecutivos que en
algunos casos han llegado a perder la
vida junto a sus familias tanto en Rusia
como fuera de Rusia Incluso en
Washington encontramos alguna historia
extraña como ésta un crítico de Putin se
cayó de un edificio en Washington fue
realmente un suicidio esto supone un
importante salto porque quiere decir que
ya ni siquiera los propios entornos del
gobierno están seguros y ahora le ha
llegado el turno a su última víctima
esta
es una fotografía de la serie del grupo
Wagner en San Petersburgo Poco después
de que se conociera el fallecimiento de
su libro El jefe del grupo Wagner héroe
de Rusia un verdadero patriota de Su
patria jeffeny vigorichen Murió como
resultado de las acciones de los
traidores a Rusia nadie debería
sorprenderse la desastrosa guerra en
Ucrania ha llevado un ejército privado a
marchar sobre Moscú y ahora parece haber
conducido a esto el propio presidente
biden ha sido muy claro claro
y ojo porque todo esto de que no ha sido
una sorpresa es estrictamente cierto sin
ir más
lejos desde el suceso
el pidió por primera vez a sus
conciudadanos que abandonarán
inmediatamente Bielorrusia puede ser que
tuvieran alguna información y que se te
miran las consecuencias en el país a
miles de soldados de Wagner sea como sea
Esto es lo que se publicaba el día 13 de
agosto tan solo 10 días antes de la
ejecución experto el líder del grupo
Wagner de Rusia será asesinado por Putin
o liberar a otro golpe de estado en un
plazo de 6 meses Putin salió la
televisión y llamó traidora sin todo el
mundo sabe lo que hacen con los
traidores y Putin no lo ha hecho pero
quiere verlo muerto vale Putin quería
verle fuera de juego de eso que habían
pocas dudas y hoy ya ninguna
no olvidéis que hace exactamente dos
meses antes del derribo del avión sin
encabezó un motín contra la cúpula del
kremlin un motín durante el que llegó a
marchar sobre Moscú durante el cual su
ejército privado derribó varias
aeronaves rusas y donde además para
colmo el jefe de los Wagner de
desacreditó la guerra en Ucrania
como todos recordaréis al final la
sublevación se paró tras alcanzarse un
acuerdo intermediado por el presidente
bielorruso Alexander lucasenco los
Wagner poner fin a su motín a cambio de
indultos de poder continuar con sus
negocios de tener un refugio seguro en
Bielorrusia y ahora ya lo veis una vez
más la lección parece Clara nunca te
fíes de Vladimir Putin un tipo que al
poco de producirse El derribo no
ocultaba su enorme satisfacción en esta
imagen que veis en pantalla el
presidente ruso ya sabía que el avión de
Wagner había sido derribado no me digáis
que no se le veía contento solo le
faltaba fumarse un puro a los Aníbal
Smith del equipo a el plan había salido
a las mil maravillas la purga estaba
prácticamente terminada Putin es el
último apóstol de la venganza Si yo
fuera pregón si no despediría mi catador
de comida y no hablamos solo de Wagner
el mismo miércoles 23 de agosto unas
horas antes del derribo del avión la
agencia oficial rusa
ria novostic confirmó la destitución de
ser gay surobi También conocido como El
general Armagedón uno de los pesos
pesados de las fuerzas armadas rusas y
el jefe de las fuerzas aeroespaciales el
motivo se sospecha que mantenía
estrechos lazos con picotsin de hecho
surobi Kim ya fue detenido tras la
sublevación de los Wagner La pregunta es
fue esta la pieza que falló aquellos
días 23 y 24 de junio eso quizá nunca lo
sepamos pero sea como sea si algo está
claro es que Putin ha dado un golpe en
la mesa y sí vale todos podíamos
imaginar que tarde o temprano el
presidente ruso intentaría vengarse Pero
porque acabar con pregotzin Y por qué
hacerlo justamente ahora qué gana el
presidente ruso con todo esto Qué
consecuencias puede tener esta ejecución
Pues bien veámoslo
el momento preciso
[Música]
queridos amigos Wagner se había
convertido en toda una molestia para el
presidente ruso Putin necesitaba Sí o sí
quitárselos de en medio Por qué pues en
primer lugar porque el hecho de que
pregotching siguiera paseándose por
Rusia era una auténtica vergüenza para
Putin y una Clara muestra de debilidad
el jefe de los Wagner le había retado le
había humillado delante toda Rusia y de
todo el mundo con su marcha sobre Moscú
y claro pensando bien ningún dictador
puede permitirse el lujo de tolerar
semejante comportamiento si lo hace
antes o después otro repetirán la jugada
pero es que además las cosas en Rusia no
van particularmente bien muchos
oligarcas y muchos militares están
terriblemente descontentos con todo lo
que ha supuesto la dichosa invasión de
Ucrania en este sentido la ejecución de
pregotching es un claro aviso Navegantes
si osáis meteros con el líder pagaréis
las consecuencias
[Música]
no solo era un Mercenario su grupo
operaba un montón de negocios diferentes
desde una fábrica de chocolate en San
Petersburgo a una destilería de vodka o
minas de oro agencias de comunicación y
desinformación o empresas de petróleo y
gas en cierta forma muchos oligarcas
pueden verse reflejados en él Y el hecho
de haber derribado el avión ni siquiera
puede ser algo casual esta ejecución no
solo ha sido muy visible sino que además
en sí mismo también es un mensaje para
las propias élites de Rusia élites que
habitualmente se mueven en aviones
privados es decir el mensaje es bastante
Claro si te enfrentas a Putin nunca más
estarás seguro
[Música]
ahora bien Estas son las razones pero
por qué Putin lo ha hecho exactamente
ahora acaso ha sido Simplemente porque
ha tenido la oportunidad puede ser pero
también hay algunos hechos que pueden
haber acelerado la toma de esta decisión
por ejemplo Puede que sea una
coincidencia O puede que no pero lo
cierto Es que las semanas anteriores se
estaban produciendo importantes cambios
en Wagner el grupo parecía estar
reestructurarándose en cientos de
soldados estaban abandonando Bielorrusia
al parecer para incorporarse a las
misiones de Wagner en África un lugar
mucho más lucrativo hablamos de Tal vez
unas 1000 o 1400 unidades y de hecho el
último vídeo en el que vimos al propio
picotching fue precisamente en África
imperatura
como
el problema Pues que si Putin quería
vengarse y recordad que era algo que
necesitaba hacer la huida de los Wagner
a África podría complicar sus planes
además el grupo podría utilizar esta
Aventura para fortalecerse Y ser un
rival más desafiante eso por no hablar
de lo que podrían suponer para su imagen
pública si los Wagner lograran algún
tanto militar las comparaciones serían
odiosas
[Música]
y de hecho esto nos lleva al segundo
motivo que tal vez explique por qué se
decidió acabar de una vez por todas con
este tema y es que fijaos Atentamente en
este vídeo en él veis la bandera
ucraniana ondeando sobre el disputado En
clave de robotineo una posición que
comenzó a lucharse en junio Y que ahora
le permite a la artillería ucraniana
atacar Toc el siguiente paso necesario
en su avance hacia melipoll sí la
contraofensiva ucraniana ha sido más
lenta de lo esperado hablaremos de ello
muy pronto aquí en visualpolitik pero lo
cierto Es que en los días anteriores al
derribo del avión las tropas ucranianas
lograron por fin algunos avances
notables
por ejemplo la cuadragésimo séptima
brigada mecanizada de Ucrania con apoyo
de la 82 brigada de asalto aéreo luego
romper las líneas defensivas cerca de
robotines lo que precipitó la caída de
esta localidad ahora esta posición le
permite al ejército ucraniano lanzar
operaciones contra líneas de defensa
relativamente más débiles y de hecho los
rusos según informaciones del instituto
guerra los rusos están intentando
fortalecer posiciones defensivas a casi
30 kilómetros del frente actual es decir
que esperan que las tropas ucranianas
puedan superar sus posiciones y avanzar
[Música]
lógicamente esto es un problema y grande
para Putin O al menos lo era brigotzin
se había apuntado el tanto de mahmud Y
encima le había retado cualquier traspié
grave en Ucrania habría sido un golpe
muy fuerte para el kremlin se les vería
como los perdedores Mientras que el jefe
de los Wagner podría reclamar su estatus
de vencedor además el parlamento ruso
tuvo que aprobar a finales de Julio una
nueva ley que autoriza el kremlin a
enviar cientos de miles de hombres más a
la guerra Eso sí esta vez la
movilización será totalmente muy
diferente
a partir de ahora el gobierno podrá
enviar solicitudes de reclutamiento
confidenciales a tantos hombres como
considere necesario Así mismo el límite
de edad de las personas que pueden ser
llamadas a filas se ha ampliado de los
27 a 30 años y también se han
incrementado los castigos por negarse a
servir al ejército y claro por muy
confidencial o silencioso que sea este
proceso no será nada popular y con esas
Mejor no tener mucha oposición bueno es
que a Putin no le ha salido bien ni
siquiera esta jugada de despiste fracasa
la primera misión Luna rusa en 47 años
la primera misión lunar de Rusia en 47
años Fue un rotundo fracaso la nave rusa
perdió el control y terminó
estrellándose contra la luna mientras
que la India lograba Poco después
aterrizar su propia nave espacial en la
luna sin ningún problema este momento es
inolvidable es fenomenal es el grito de
victoria de una nueva India así que qué
queréis que os diga es muy posible que
todos estos hechos hayan influido y
mucho a la hora de acelerar los planes
de Moscú digamos que entre unas cosas y
otras dar un golpe en la mesa y cargar
se aplicóptzin empezaba a aparecer algo
urgente y eso es exactamente lo que han
hecho ahora bien la última pregunta que
tenemos que responder es exactamente Qué
consecuencias puede tener este golpe que
significa esta ejecución pues prestad
mucha pero que mucha atención
las consecuencias
queridos amigos amigas podemos encontrar
cuatro consecuencias directas de la
caída de pregotzin a corto y medio plazo
parece que Putin sale reforzado le
habían echado un pulso no parecía estar
ganándolo y de repente zas tumbado el
kremlin parece estar cerrando sus
grietas por otro lado la ejecución tal y
como se ha llevado a cabo va a
multiplicar la paranoia general y esto
esto también supone un problema para el
kremlin si Hasta ahora ha quedado Clara
La burbuja de información en la que vive
Vladimir Putin ahora esto puede verse
reforzado trabajar con un autócrata
despiadado no te invita a mojarte mucho
más bien todo lo contrario nadie va a
estar dispuesto a asumir
responsabilidades si en 2021 y 2022 le
convencieron a Putin de que Ucrania
caería en dos o tres días ahora la cosa
puede ponerse peor Por ejemplo si ya era
conocido que las personas que forman
parte del círculo íntimo de Putin y de
la élite rusa están incrementando su
seguridad ahora eso puede dispararse Ya
nadie Está seguro en Rusia
Por otra parte la caída de pregosin
probablemente marque el fin del grupo
Wagner es muy probable que sus negocios
terminen siendo repartidos entre
diferentes oligarcas o directamente
incluso absorbidos por el gobierno ruso
sin embargo esto supondrá perdernos Solo
una importante estructura militar sino
que también muy probablemente reducirá
la influencia de Rusia en África
Y por último queda claro que negociar
computing no resulta fácil no importa si
hablamos de pregotching de Ucrania o de
cualquier otro tema el presidente ruso
rara vez cumple su palabra sea como sea
con la información que tenemos a la hora
de preparar Este vídeo Putin parece
salir reforzado pero ojo que todavía
tiene una guerra en marcha un creciente
descontento entre los militares y una
situación poco halagüeña en casa la
partida no ha hecho más que comenzar
pero llegas hasta aquí ahora el turno es
para ti qué valoración haces de la caída
de brigotching crees que esto consolida
por mucho tiempo la posición de Putin en
Rusia Cuáles piensas que serán los
próximos pasos del kremling déjanos tus
impresiones en los comentarios y
hablamos debate y ahora si este vídeo te
ha resultado interesante No olvides
darle al botón de like y suscribirte
visualpolitik si es que aún no lo has
hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]